thanks christian and i'm glad you know i
heard you actually give me a partial
credit for wesley seoul's career
given that i organized
the billionaire i never mentioned you i
never mentioned youtube but it didn't
matter
without
which entire story well that was the
exact same month i also transferred
federation from the philippines to the
united states
and also that was pretty much the same
amount i got my green card
and also the time when i decided to go
professional
right so that hundred thousand that me
and my partner amy lee
was quite helpful yeah thank you very
much for that okay christian you didn't
give me credit but there's wesley
i'm just taking a little bit i just want
a little bit of credit probably it was
partly your money too honda
that funded my professional career
well we won't get into don wesley but
let's get into the u.s championship and
you had a of course that for millionaire
chess you had a final round against your
former teammate and
uh dorm mate ray robson you've faced
many times since then and now you face
him today what were your thoughts coming
into this round knowing that there was a
three-way tie for first you were part of
that and a win by any of your
co-competitors
would force you to have to win i wasn't
thinking of the points at all i was
just very [ __ ] very tired uh
i i think i met playing non-stop pretty
much the last three months because we
had this term in st louis and also in
between those uh i had this online
tournaments which are very tough uh
you play the best players in the world
and then you have to wake up every
single day at seven in the morning for
nine ten days
so i think i'm pretty much playing
non-stop and
considering how badly i'm playing the
tournament i just wanted to finish it
uh i've been blundering left and right
the the last couple of games couldn't
see the wins and all that
so it's clearly something is wrong so i
need to work harder in my chest uh but
the good thing is after this tournament
i won't have any over the board i'm ski
i'm skipping riga precisely for that
reason the grand swiss
i am skipping that because it's a very
tough open
so i really need to to work hard on my
chest get back into shape prepare also i
wasn't really able to prepare anything
for this tournament coming in because as
i said i was playing online
and so
yeah it's not the best tournament could
have gone better could have gone worse
so i just uh wanted to play solidly
today but if fabi draws
then he deserves the championship
then it's not oh if he draws oh yeah
it's not over and you still have to play
tomorrow there'll be a playoffs yeah so
you don't get to rent there's no rest
for the weary yeah that's true if it
draws and lanier wins there'll be a
four-way tie for first mm-hmm
i don't think lenderman has very good
chance to win so
so yeah you're right then we'll all be
back here tomorrow we're gonna have fun
we're gonna celebrate no no sleep yeah
also the last time i blocked that
fabian's position seems like uh black
has a very solid position with the
bishop there
anything can happen but
uh yeah fabian wins it he deserves to to
win i think yesterday showed amazing
fighting spirit he wasn't
he wasn't playing
uh his best chess like he wasn't playing
perfect chess but he has the will and
experience to to keep fighting and
outplay the lower rated opponents like
yesterday i thought he had a suspicious
position a couple points i think alex
even had some chances to win at certain
points but
fab is very experienced a fighter and he
never gives up
but yeah it'll be exciting if he draws
then we get we get some very
very exciting uh
uh play-ups i'm not exactly sure how it
works uh it's not very common that there
will be three people or or more dying
for first no it's not uh let me ask you
you said you're skipping riga which is
an opportunity to qualify for the world
chess championship you have thousands
and thousands of fans out there who'd
love to see you compete in the
candidates
what would be your path to the
candidates if not riga yeah i'm playing
in the in the grand prix i think i'm
qualified there sam shanklin also
qualifies i think qualified by rating
i think other people also like fabiano
qualifies there by rating
but uh
grand prix will be
next february i believe it's
a series of three tournaments if i
remember correctly you play two
tournaments and then they count your
whoever's leading after
after two or three tournaments gets to
kind of spot so i'll i i have to
work hard on my chest for that and
that'll be my next major thing uh i've
fallen for the same trick before i
played in isle of man grand swiss two
years ago but opens are hard because you
play all these 2600s and then they play
very solidly uh they're they're happy
with a draw with with both colors pretty
much so it's very difficult last time i
i played for two hard weeks very
difficult tournament and
i think i earned 1500 bucks
for that so i've been better staying off
at home also
i mean there's a two candidate spots but
at the same time there are 120 players
so uh also i think at this point uh i'm
pretty much start and going there with
no preparation will lead to disaster
okay all right well uh i'll let you get
your rest as you see whether or not fabi
can win his game and maybe there'll be a
playoffs tomorrow yeah hopefully yeah
and get some wraps and thanks for the
credit uh the partial credit
we got haters on the panel who never
want to give me credit for that yeah i
want to ask you how amy lee is doing i
mean she's doing wow she's doing it oh
that's great to hear yeah emily is such
a great person i i think millionaire
chess in 2014 was one of the best
tournaments i've ever played i think i
barely made any mistakes in that
tournament so
uh
and that certainly the money certainly
helped convince me that there's a future
playing professional chess
and you know christians shouldn't argue
because
he won money in millionaire as well oh
yeah
he wanted to be uh
i won the uh under 25 50 section what
was it in 2016.
he's never said thank you maurice for
organizing that he did i think there's
the one thank you i shook your hand on
the stage i took your money and i said
thank you
marie we gotta do that again
um
wesley i do have a question for you
because again this was such an important
game a key key game now just only one
moment here in this position for me play
the kind of soft move i understand your
mindset as you played the move f to f3
i didn't understand why you didn't play
knight takes d7 obviously he's got to go
queen takes d7 you would take on f6 he
would take on f6 more or less the same
structure that you got in the game and
here's the tempo against the queen now
if you're playing to win right you know
and things like that you know there is a
terrible trap in the position like
that's a blunder because c6 and you got
queen g4 so uh this certainly flashed
through your mind but you
declined to play it this way
because i think uh sorry d texas yeah
this position has been played like in 10
15 games before already okay black plays
queen 37 and then
i think this is one of the games with
the nine drawers yes yeah i think thing
lyran played this with black he had some
draws you also i've been played before
but yeah i didn't analyze
is that h4
maybe queen g4 check okay seems like it
wins upon hacking h7
c takes p6
but maybe it's a dangerous one to accept
you're very undeveloped of course yeah
yeah probably
yeah and then queen d4
but uh
yeah that's a problem
computers just give zeros here these
days so
but still i'm very disappointed with the
fact that i
i mean it's hard to get any chances in
the tournament but i got very good
chances in my game against daniel a few
rounds ago so i'm still very
disappointed that i think that was my
best chance to win the tournament
outright but
i think yeah i've been blundering lesson
right in the last few games wesley if i
may get your opinion there's a dramatic
turn of events in the game with sam and
fabi as farming play queen of three
fainting at the pawn on b7 and the
response by sam was the move f5 not your
more traditional solid move that you
would expect this move with a key move
uh if we may look at it on yasser's
screen
your thoughts about such a move and the
position that has transpired as a result
f5
well that ef6 ef6 and queen f3 has been
played yeah that seems like a typical
sam shanklin move where he's not uh he
always looks for counterplay he's not
satisfied with passive defending
like f5 i guess looks looks okay because
you cannot take on b7 as black as c5
i mean
or
yeah maybe it should be seven or before
huh it's just equal
rook d4 west i think so yeah rook b4
looks fine
i don't know i couldn't see moves very
clearly uh
at this time of the day but i think
i think basically with the bishop pair
and also very sold dark square control
black
if out of so what about the way he
played the game he played of the game he
took an f6 and then he played queen e3
yeah i think it's the
only way to keep the game going because
black has to be a bit careful with this
weekend light squares on the king side
uh
but i mean i don't know what black's
best move is like
it seems like it's very close to
equality
uh
maybe we should
hard to say
will you be keeping a close eye on this
game or you're going to go have lunch
and relax and
wait for the phone call
yeah i'll just relax i mean
it's out of my hands now whatever
happens
happens
uh i think i gave a shot
at a discernment so at this point
i'll just swatch the game lightly but uh
and and hope that the sam place is good
just
right all right we'll let you go get
that relaxation in yeah but of course we
still want to work an extra day tomorrow
oh we are so anxious wesley yeah you
have no idea
you can't dance it you can't partner yet
nice blazer by the way like the i like
the
crest st louis chesca yeah okay thank
you wesley good luck in case of a tie
breaks